في السودان يسود الهدوء الحذر جبهات
القتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمه الخرطوم في اليوم الثالث من
الهدنه وكانت اشتباكات قد دارت بين
الجانبين في نهايه اليوم الثاني من الهدنه
هدنه الايام السبعه فقد اتهم الجيش قوات
الدعم السريع بانتهاك الهدنه المعلنه وقال
انه ابلغ الجهات الراعيه للاتفاق لكن من
وصفها بالميليشيا المتمرده لم تستجب لاي
من مطالب الهدنه واكد الجيش التزامه
بالمحافظه على الهدنه الانسانيه
في المقابل اتهمت قوه دعم السريع الجيش
بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه وقصف مواقع قوات
الدعم في عده محاور وقالت قوات الدعم
السريع انها ملتزمه بالهدنه الانسانيه
ودعت قوه الدعم السريع من وصفتهم
بالانقلابيين الى الالتزام بالهدنه
الانسانيه واحترام اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار